here's an idea about social media
developed through social media from elon
which is um uh you know everyone freaks
out because they think either you know
oh he's gonna do less content
moderations the left is freaking out
because they want more content
moderation the right is celebrating
because they think the people doing the
content moderation are on the left
but there was a there was a one i think
was a tweet um where he said like three
things he was going to do to make it
better and was you know defeat the bots
or something but he said um authenticate
all humans yeah and this is a hugely
important statement um and it's pretty
powerful that this guy can put three
words in a tweet and actually i think
this could change the world even if the
bid fails the fact that elon said that
that he thinks we need to authenticate
all humans is huge
because now um
we're talking about solutions here
what can we do to make social media a
better place for democracy a place that
actually makes democracy better
as tristan harris has pointed out
social media and digital technology the
chinese are using it really skillfully
to make a better authoritarian nation
and by better i don't mean morally
better i mean like more stable
successful
whereas we're using it to make ourselves
weaker more fragmented and more insane
so
we're on the way down we're in big
trouble
and um
all the argument is about content
moderation and what we learned from
francis haugen is that what five or ten
percent of what what she what they might
call hate speech gets caught one percent
of violence intimidation content
moderation even if we do a lot more of
it isn't going to make a big difference
all the
all the powers in the dynamics changes
to the architecture and as i said in my
atlantic article uh what are the reforms
that would matter for social media and
the number one thing i said the number
one thing i believe is
user authentication or user verification
and people freak out and they say like
you know oh but we need anonymous like
yeah fine you can be anonymous but um
what i think needs to be done is anyone
can open an account on you know twitter
facebook whatever as long as you're over
16 and that's another piece once you're
16 or 18
at a certain age you can be treated like
an adult you can open an account and you
can look you can read
and you can make up whatever fake name
you want
but if you want to post if you want the
viral amplification on a company that
has section 230 protection from lawsuits
which is a very special privilege i
understand the need for it but it's an
incredibly powerful privilege to protect
them from lawsuits
if you want to be able to post um on
platforms that as we'll get to in the
google doc there's a lot of evidence
that they are undermining and damaging
democracy um then the company has this
this minimal minimal responsibility has
to meet
banks have know your customer laws you
can't just walk up to a bank with a bag
of money that you stole and say here
deposit this for me my name's john smith
you have to actually show who you are
and the bank isn't going to announce who
you are publicly but you have to if
they're going to do business with you
they need to know you're a real person
uh um not a criminal
and so there's a lot of schemes for how
to do this there's multiple levels
people don't seem to understand this
level zero of authentication is nothing
that's what we have now level one this
might be what elon meant authenticate
all humans meaning you have to at least
pass a capture or some test to show
you're not a bot there's no identity
there's nothing just something that you
know it's a constant cat and mouse
struggle between bots and huma you know
so we try to just filter out pure bonds
the next level up there are a variety of
schemes that allow you to authenticate
identity in ways that are not traceable
or kept
so
some whether you show an id whether you
use biometric whether you have something
something on the blockchain that
establishes identity whether it's linked
to a phone whatever it is there are
multiple schemes now that companies have
figured out um for how to do this and so
if you did that then in order to get an
account where you have posting
privileges on facebook or twitter or
tick tock or whatever
you have to at least do that and if you
do that
you know
now
um now
the other people are real humans too
and suddenly our public square is a lot
nicer because you don't have bots
swarming around this would also cut down
on trolls you still have trolls who use
their real name but this would just make
it a little scarier for trolls
some men turn into complete [ __ ]
they can be very polite in real life
but some men as soon as they have the
anonymity they start using racial slurs
they're horrible
one troll can ruin thousands of people's
day
you